[Music]
what's up how's it going Jake Decker
Mike mehar dear here we playing
Wolfenstein to the new Colossus skidding
this is Wolfenstein the new order from
2014 from Bethesda Softworks and machine
games of course after e3 one of the big
talking points was Wolfenstein - the new
Colossus will be releasing on October
27th which you and I are pretty pumped
about yeah I I really like this game
when it came out but I didn't realize
how much I liked it until yeah and like
it yeah when it got announces like all
right I'm really excited for this game
it yeah they showed a lot of it
Bethesda's press conference for the
second game now we are figured it'd be a
good time to go back and stream this
what other shooters metro exits also got
announced yeah we'll be talking about
Metro last light a lot on a reboot this
week
I said yeah if you watch reboot at all
the show that Jake and I do most of time
we're gonna try to actually stride I
want to talk over this cutscene too much
actually I'll I don't know if people
care too much about washing these so
I'll just be quiet I guess I'd turn it
up a little bit we skip the first
mission just you know because the first
mission night the flashback yeah more
like a typical World War 2 game yeah
it's very like follow the leader sort of
thing yeah so if you haven't played this
game and you want to play a new order
before will the sign to comes out there
probably will be a little bit a few
spoilers this is about an hour ish into
the game after the intro this is when
the game gets good in my opinion
yeah this setup is so good in this game
yeah we didn't wanna start from
beginning for those in the YouTube
twitch chats they did with the chats up
we don't want star from beginning
because the beginning is not that great
and we figured it'd be more entertaining
to watch yeah I mean we figured - will
stream for like an hour and a half maybe
a little bit less and if we played the
first mission we won't get the good
stuff till after yeah
Buju [ __ ] oh yeah
that's also on your Stroud's from Gears
War I forgot Anya was in this
mental asylum
yeah till you meet her
one thing I was thinking about is that
there's a lot of wheelchairs in
Wolfenstein Wolfenstein - they're saying
there's that machine where you hurt in a
wheelchair and this you start out in a
wheelchair yeah listen be a motif yeah
psych hold on YouTube old blood is also
really good i seven played old blood
it's good
and so it's weird you see dishonored
definitely outsider and uncharted The
Lost Legacy coming up those standalone
DLCs old blood if I'm not mistaken you
don't need to have played or owned
Wolfenstein new order but it's more uh
she's coaching yeah it's more uh joking
you know more stealth focused in my
opinion even though you can be stealthy
game especially when you're taking out
the officers I can call in
reinforcements he'll be a stealthy
strange sensation trapped in my body I
love his monologue black out losing time
yeah sometimes a season weird how cool
the character he becomes by how like
having trouble generic he seems
anticipate like a settler win
here's what I know I'll let Poland
Hospital know that's sane asylum she's
dead
soundtracks unreal yeah shrink of the
score I guess you could say we were
saying I run the pitch the voice actor
for EJ blast was Chris also Rose I'm
Casper old notes sometimes
what were you saying he's calm he is his
name is Shawn let me double check us I
believe it's Brian bloom who if you play
call of duty infinite warfare your
protagonist his facial model his MO caps
and his voice are all fists voice actor
so voice actor for BJ bless image is
like in infinite warfare he also helps
write it yeah uh he's at infinity warden
her name is Anya that's pretty good care
yeah she takes care of everyone
she holds his place together she's
supposed to be married by now
yes since this game Brian wasn't sorry
Brian bloom was the voice actor um he's
very good voice actor uh in this game
and into the warfare game played it but
also just like in terms of mocap and his
presence on the screen is really good
cool guy in general to to talk to about
like the engine work on Wolfie sighs bye
come on I hope we get to the part with
the chainsaw fight this farce pretty rad
too though
pretty brutal there's Buddha but I love
how the the color comes back right when
yeah hang on Oh what's the point of the
pillow to stop a blood splattering on
him yeah I think quiet brutal Julie
yeah so you see a signal detected those
are the officers that have like radios
to reinforcement so they're pretty
helpful to clear out first silently if
possible surprise him do it do you not
get when do you get the silence because
you start getting obviously you could do
a wheel to salt rifles not that much
farther into the game they waste no time
yeah I can't I wrong I'm pretty sure and
then you can silent you get like an
alternate silenced pistol Oh thought you
missed him thought I did too oh there's
double pistols I think you might be able
to silence your weapons right now or no
you but you probably ought to pick it up
actually I don't know if I yeah I don't
think I can silence yet but I can
definitely do a wield yeah for those
asking we are playing this on pc right
now jake and i prefer controllers for
this game but it is on pc
hey buddy we're over a little more
animations yeah actually I've been
replaying on Metro last light recently I
didn't get this weekend - for a reboot
episode and just to get ready for Exodus
even though I know that's not coming out
till next year but when you go to
assassinate someone despite how much
more polished last light is then 2033
its predecessor it when you go to stab
them it's you'll go to slit their throat
and then their audio will be like huh
but as you're slitting their throats
it's really weird sometimes that that's
their reaction to a knife being in their
jugular and then like doom which salt I
mean Bethesda has a really good track
record of bringing back each other
shooters between this bedroom and
hopefully quake champions is good but I
don't think that's not really my kind of
game I don't think I'll get that into
quake champions yeah I wasn't I mean I
didn't think this would be as good as it
is and it's true it's very true same
with doom I didn't think Doom would be
as good as it was either yeah
that's a first pistol is it all time is
there an alternate fire I don't think
there's no pretty get the tick off
analyst game and health I know it's kind
of a pain like health is okay but ammo
is like manually but I like I'd like
that there's a health system that as
opposed to now you can like overcharge
your health Big O or big 0 ecology on
YouTube is saying you have a silencer
for pistol isn't it till the checkpoint
before the train station in a little bit
yeah Robert durin jr. on YouTube the new
game will release on October 27 assuming
your time alone fine if you're talking
about quake champions
I'm actually not positive I can look
that up though I don't think there's any
really say yeah it's still in beta isn't
it there wasn't it recently wasn't bait
well it might still be in beta I was
doing able totally invaded again because
it seems like with a game like that you
didn't want to do lots of like beta
tests and stuff gotcha
and then the silencer makes the pistol
single shot right now it's burst
well that's me the mag sac or from a
perfect dark perfect dark zero game's
underrated oh my god overrated give me
credit drive grenades I don't know
no Oleg I couldn't eat though there's
one it leans pretty big yeah like you
like to lean under doors and stuff I
want a grenade I can't go back out now I
can't go back in you might get him out
here there you go
whatever oh [ __ ]
gotta make sure he's dead you know
yeah it would be too careful with Nazis
that was bad
on the uber difficulty this came to be
really tough
Wow did not think that was going to
explode
there's some really good missions in
this game - yeah like the I don't spoil
anything but there's
oh [ __ ] oh my god
yeah do you member the plane the old
school Wolfenstein levels that you can
find oh yeah yeah and when you're like
wandering around the base or whatever
yeah where's that said yeah the second
one is going from Europe to America
occupied America
I rarely do wheelies auricles unless
it's like medium range close range
yeah if you like me you're like tight
quarters but it looks cool especially
for like the stream I also love that
you're in a straitjacket
the October 27 when new Colossus
releases is also Super Mario Odyssey
Viva you're into those that's which
library or Assassin's Creed origins and
then about two weeks for that is the
evil within
- and then shadow of war is a little bit
laughter after the 27th or after shadow
for it's between it's a Friday between
shadow sorry it's a Friday between evil
within - no no evil within - as a Friday
the 13th shadow war believes the
following Tuesday which would be like
the 17th 18th or something and then two
weeks after that is this game and that's
great origins tomorrow I'm like I know
people were complaining that this III
wasn't as good but I think one cool
thing about this III is that most the
games people are really excited for
gonna come out this year it's well yeah
especially Bethesda they did announce
anything 2018 I mean I guess yeah
there's exceptions Metro Exodus he has
next year Beyond Good and Evil - I'm is
never going to come out and if it does
it's going to suck sorry if you don't
like that any of it what I think yeah
what else got announced from like next
year on red that wasn't really there if
it's gonna be out spring as of now yeah
rockstars never gonna bring their games
in October is the month right now and
then a week after this everything I'm
actually pretty kind of excited for
college new world war 2 yeah
a little bit after that would be a
battle for it too
[Music]
what version is PCI Succession damn
brutal would you really want to pick a
fight with a guy who looks like him be
he's in a straitjacket see he's covered
in blood
it's the Billiam Jane laughs Commission
ranger Army USA USA
I'm sorry my polish isn't very good are
you fit to drive
where to
wherever
wherever the road takes us
I love the characters their resistances
yeah
all right you have that like hub right
the resistance hub that you go back to
between yeah I don't remember how many
times you go back to might only be like
two or three times
all right far cry 5 is February we've
seen a lot of that for coming out next
year but if they all like show those off
there's actually a few things I know
it's like August destiny to September
yeah forget about destiny - that's the
big one
then there's also like splatoon - is
soon what the ADA July something
mid-july doesn't Mario in rabbits about
the 27th - uh no no Mario + rabbits is
end of July or maybe no August it's the
same day no July 27th yeah yeah same day
as XCOM two's expansion which is funny
jeez they're clearly emulating an ex-con
- with that game see I'm actually
weirdly excited for Mario + rabbits me -
I don't care about rabbits
I like Mario like most people he's 60
the seamless dupe you've stayed with us
for 14 years
it's 1960 there's a good scene yes among
crews have to find a way to contact the
US military I gotta find my you really
normal life really there's no more war
it's over no more Milica no the war
ain't over look at all these Nazis
walking around they won it's over did
not you screw the world now they're
everywhere yeah malware bear what about
the youth shut up during cutscenes USA
yeah what's the word put that you
surrender
I surrendered because of you oh gosh I
Tom bomb they surrendered 12 years ago
when Nazi atompub their country Hey
well then I'll find the resistance I'll
find them and I'll help them fight more
resistance
everyone is captured if they live did
not you have them and who can say well
they came them yeah this seems rad
working on behalf of generous tossing
himself do you know how much misfortune
you are in if you do not release me
there's no point in keeping me here me
production is my protection
like you do you realize I am
it kinda like the new doom there's a lot
of incentive to search around yeah
upgrade the one uh people like you just
stabbing you it I think you picked up a
screwdriver yeah let me tell you how
this is gonna work I'm gonna ask you one
question you are gonna answer that
question in a way I find satisfactory
and if you do not I will saw your head
off with this here appliance you hear me
so here it comes where are you people
keeping the captured resistance fighters
I'm sure I don't know what you're
talking about there is no resistance
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
dammit look if you want to know the
resistance fighters where are they
Darlene Aizen fights pleasant but you'll
never make it
if checkpoints everywhere looking for
you looking for you looking for you and
than us and soon ever find this place
and then you will be on your knees
[Music]
Veronica okay yeah
yes this pistoi you walk by a bus coffee
yeah like a sport jacket on a new
Colossus yeah yeah or he's running that
suit yeah oh yeah boo yay Fred that
hebrew name of it as it was with me
Mischa I will get just night he's there
did you shoot it across me um I'm sure
I'm sure
yes maybe Aramis you do Bettina Vijay is
the size of a fridge
probably yeah we ask for your mercy Lord
as we make to journey across dark waters
krottas sound feet
refuge from the storm a little bit of
gore gave it a head pop their heads off
but yeah that cuts away for the score
you're the happy and safe passage
there's Gore for ya
was it stabbing the dateline Hanshin to
the road it's not safe
you'll kill face you want to play now
should I stay with car no switch spots
yeah I can do the chat or use myself I
can I can do it from here right we wait
for you here kill everyone
yeah hey everyone so what's the stage of
stage of production of this version uh
this is the France this is all scar PC
of your new order yeah reacquaint myself
with the controls if you hold down right
bumper it's how you cycle through after
they pull the L or left trigger you're
not left trigger left bumper and then
you can do the vein of stuff all right
wait it's very much everything
I remember this was like kind of the
first mission in this give me kind of
like pick there's a little there's more
options to go about it right Robert
Duran jr. says he remembers reading that
a lot of they removed a lot of Nazi
imagery in this did they do it for the
US version though I don't know I don't
think they did it for the US version
there you go
yeah cool and then I said how do I do
the do the what switch from silencer to
that I don't remember let me check that
really fast it is all gonna be under
this isn't it yes why not going to be
probably to go to controller next one
there we go
um here we go where's alternate fire
toggle fire mode right right sure it's
so yeah I got ya sweet all right I got
it
certain thing I need to go and play this
one
right near one of the dudes
things right above you
well yes
another way I try stealth as long as
possible yeah usually he tilt this
monitor toward me a little bit more [ __ ]
player fritz says good lighting but
graphics are a bit ps3 ish looking yeah
they are this game released on the ps3
PS ps3 and xbox one is for Xbox 360 as
well so graphically it's not as good as
it could be nice however the new
Colossus as you probably know is just
coming to Xbox one ps4 and PC so I think
that game-mode nice and pretty I think
there's a sniper up here yeah can I not
go through that door yeah
she's going to pick that up later yeah I
think yeah that's Oh
yeah I prefer to go okay so it looks
like I can just go store here we go
I look hurt oh yeah at the watch oh it's
did it earlier how the [ __ ] this work
there you go
yes I think that ladder back there will
get you into or get you to where the
sniper rifle is grenade
start picking dudes off mr. McCree asked
for fallout new vegas or Wolfenstein two
new Colossus I mean I understand that
yeah I'm not sure bears this 9-3 check
my silence this no I could start he's
doing this now once I kill the officer I
can find him
he's probably inside probably stay sound
a little bit
man I hate ladders and games hey Bob
Jones Chris a says Mike and Jake guys
which FPS shooter game franchise do you
think has come the farthest in terms of
its graphics since the first incarnation
it's a good question mean I think if
you're looking at the history games we
do yeah I do do look good but doom is
also like as old-school as you get yeah
I'll go over here finish this on to uber
difficulty recently Dan yeah that is
foodle back Killam I sure hope so
sounded like you should knock this
helmet off I thought in this game it was
still xqo counsel headshot just which
sounds you can hear that what's that
he's a help oh no it's not gold egg dope
you know you can do with gold eggs what
oh they see you what I would know
they're talking to someone else
oh [ __ ] another talk about me all right
II meant which is better fallout 3 or
fallout 4 fallout 3 dad say fallout 3 as
well - whoops
now whatever kills me
where this officer
Oh
quick draw mcgraw that's what they call
you in high school at least they didn't
really stick you just came up with that
booth I don't turn the game down a
little bit
got a little bit louder who did you save
in the first mission oh man he didn't
save the Scottish dude yeah so I forget
their name it was Ferguson Ferguson
Sully
no that's uncharted yeah
uh yeah I don't know furgus just I
wouldn't talk with him so I chose him
because he seems like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
so since this is my second place here I
picked the one that wasn't Fergus I
think oh yeah really should have tried
to be more careful about not getting
spotted it this makes for more
interesting uh yeah
fight greetings difficulty this is the
medium difficulty because we figured you
wouldn't want to watch this die Bunch
yeah probably could've stepped it up
though the next one we're probably not
goober now
why it why it's the other one yeah damn
that falling damage is not didn't I
don't think PJ would that hurt Bob Jones
and so you dual wield some shotguns yeah
when I get them I will once small gripe
I have this game I love it it's like
open-ended and you can kind of find your
way around but sometimes it was - yeah
big I'm where to go which I mean I again
I don't I don't want them to hold my
hand but it would still be nice to have
a little bit like half-life 2 I was
playing this morning randomly for well
not randomly for a reboot episode or
like last light or met the last light
pretty open-ended they're pretty good
about kind of hinting where to go
ah yes you like oh my god right now
looks like xi1 d hijack as Mike and Jake
does BJ blaskowitz look exactly like are
similar to inglourious basterds start
sergeant Stiglitz and his appearance
political ad glitz in his appearance and
manner towards Nazis what do you think I
definitely see some similarities
you can tell they took some inspiration
from inglourious basterds however I
think at first it meets it kind of
seemed like he was very similar to Hugo
Stiglitz
but I feel like he kind of becomes his
own character near the end not even noon
yet lettered bold game yes this is no
you know at 2014 ya old blood gets a lot
more supernatural and kind of
the name for an all-day
[ __ ] you whoops
I don't think I was supposed to know
whoops stop with the grenade all right
you know what
all right Chris today is another
question Mike and Jake guys the new
Unreal Tournament game uses for IRC is
still in development II don't you think
it'll go versus with the new quake and
do you think it sorry
kind of far away Unreal Tournament 4
versus new quake will it become as
popular on YouTube basically is he
saying do you think the Unreal
Tournament 4 will go up against quake
and do you think it'll be so competing
in a small way with lawbreakers like
that kind of game I think Wake has far
more closure and will do far better in
terms of numbers III think I think quake
will definitely come out on top la break
is actually pretty fun that one's for
some reason yeah I was playing I finally
played at e3 I was kinda one of those
people who like didn't [ __ ] only a lot
of people [ __ ] on it but I like I just
didn't interest me but I finally played
I'm like alright this is actually pretty
fun I see what they're trying to do but
it seems like quake will be the go-to
for most people interested in those kind
of shooters but yeah someone also keeps
saying this is on sale this is on sale
on Steam for like 10 bucks right now to
go with what so if you're interested in
playing this before the new one or
replaying it cool nice free cheap right
now
Robert Durant says yeah I'm wondering
how they're lining up the wolfenstein
store you guys know anything about that
it's a trilogy right at least so new
Colossus is like the 70s whereas this is
like what 1960 something six I think if
you it's a few years at sixty right now
okay
Mayweather MacGregor Mayweather yeah
unless you take a dive I just come back
here whoops yeah you're already here
don't jump you're gonna yeah I'm not
gonna make that what's the difference
between the two guys you picked to save
I actually don't think there's much of a
difference resin change the story all
that well it's just like interactions
any much see see different guys around
the hub and [ __ ] like that
oh yeah you have to turn on the lift I
think you go up it I just went down it
okay never mind I don't know here we go
the one thing I would change in this
game uh I don't know
the in a row although I don't know the
intro circuit or best [ __ ] you yeah
sounds pistol
PJ's like 50 years old in the new game
yeah he's gonna be pretty old yeah
will you come from
so this is not the Wolfenstein game that
I've seen trailers for no this is 2014's
Wolfenstein new order the predecessor
the predecessor to the new Colossus if
we had new Colossus we definitely be
playing that right now but it's yeah we
got a ways to go before that comes out
crusade disagrees he thinks Unreal
Tournament 4 will be will be the winner
of them now quake champions Bethesda's
marketing and the way they back games
will be let me Ida critically I have no
idea if that's what you're asking but
like commercially it'll be yeah quake
looking much better how are we going
where is this I'm just going like a
background I think there's a way it go
back here I thought so at least oh god I
got this pipe maybe that's in case I
fall
there's Wolfenstein new order an old
blood have DLC uh [ __ ] I mean the old
blood was kind of DLC it was like
standalone DLC for the new order that's
weird why would they lead you down there
I mean I think you I can I just don't
feel like platforming right now rather
just go kill these people go this way
come on look at that signal yeah
on the right direction well I see see
bad guys probably
overcharged yeah you get that cheap him
for doing it to 200 remember oh hi
signal terminated along with his throat
damn good thing he didn't hear that was
that are you guys playing the whole game
we don't have time to play the whole
game but that would be cool yeah I mean
not on stream but I might keep playing
tonight lifetime you can also lean under
the car - oh yeah down on it yeah and
under doors and stuff shoot their feet
often Stein the new Colossus building
yes this game does have an amazing story
this might be one of my favorite
first-person shooter stories at least
it's in like the top 10 or so yeah it's
really good so saying that up top I'm
assuming Neal Evans says hi how's it
going thanks for stopping by checking
out this stream watching us play there's
a little Finn Stein damn Oh
oh and a lift or without you just spider
thing coming damn why is this late maybe
it's through the sniper
I feel like you get back up there second
ladder there we go nope yes not
the rail stop it damn it won't go there
we go we go no time goes for that
where's the other way to get up there
stairs of course there's knots where I
came from the angry raccoon is pointing
out mario odyssey AZ origins and
Wolfenstein new Colossus all the same
day yet Mike and I were talking about
that earlier oh you can play curious in
the chat what are you guys gonna play
first out of those three games what
would you play first I think Mike
already said he's going to do new
Colossus first and then Odyssey and
Odyssey Assassin's Creed barring
anything has to do forward yeah which I
can't complain um also another question
I can't pronounce his name but he says
Mike what is your favorite game of e3
this year my favorite game Facebook
morning I see yes I just like a lot of
people
although due process looks really fun
wolf and Mario Creed the new origin SC
yeah that's what I'm playing first bar m
plus rabbits I don't know people who
know me know that I'm a huge come to fan
which I can't wait for Mario and rabbits
to combine that I don't care about the
rabbits but just Mario I'm excited for
that game and how whimsical it looks for
that kind of game I do want the shotguns
a Vulcan goz wants to know do you
automatically pick things up in two or
do you have to manually or you have to
pick on manually oh I don't think we
know do we I don't know I think we're
playing it soon and actually get the
chance to play it yeah all right
I wish I was crouching like how much
should be saving these health rather
than overcharging right now
Family Guy family guy says it's 2:30 6
a.m. in my country I need to sleep good
night guys good night thank you for
stopping by and checking this out a
little bit
Jake are you excited for Star Wars
Battlefront - uh yes I'm excited I
didn't like Star Wars Battlefront 1 that
much in fact I really did not like it
because I was a huge fan of the original
Star Wars Battlefront 2 and I thought
battlefront was kind of a letdown
however from what I've seen with
battlefront to the 2017 battlefront - it
looks looks pretty dang good it seems
like they've made it a little bit more
new osami a little bit more to do in
this one
robo-dog damnit [ __ ]
I've never played a Wolfenstein game but
this is a good one to start with
you gotta kill that guy yeah
did you want to see a new Fallout games
your mic ah it was a nice but I don't
mind not seeing it I guess you ever
gonna be here it'll be a little 6 first
oh well unless like they do a spin-off
city another spin-off which right now
they're doing huh because there were all
those rumors about like Fallout New
Orleans right yeah like obsidian doing
one they had a project Louisiana and
there's a lot of references to New
Orleans and a few T but it seems like
Bethesda strategy for e3 is like talk to
you is like announce like sure announce
a games that are coming out that later
that year so everybody going he our
focus yeah let the VR stuff but yeah
fall for they didn't officially
announced like three months before
release Todd Howard said oh this is
coming out in October or whatever
November and then also fallout shelters
live now you can play that that's a
pretty good press conference two years
ago right yes I believe so
to the 15 but yeah I have a feeling
we'll probably see elder scrolls first
gigs i preorder battlefront 2 for the
beta
I don't know typically I don't pre-order
games I just like to wait and see but if
you really like Star Wars Battlefront 1
then I would say do it because it seems
like this is just a much better Star
Wars Battlefront 1
yeah we've actually like shooter aspect
and so yeah instead of like an arcade a
like spectacle yeah where's that
what does grenade button this
presentation for this year was week we
were talking about this I don't I I wish
they had maybe like one they teased one
game that was coming out in the future
maybe uh maybe like Elder Scrolls six or
fallout or some other could have easily
done however I think it was really cool
that everything they talked about is
coming out this year yeah metal dog Oh
we're getting that turret no Chuck yeah
while I want the [ __ ] out of shoot it
doesn't have ammo oh they use like an
EMP thing I thought you just forgot how
to shoot it's right trigger Mike didn't
work okay sure
- the trick these guys in there take a
weak spot I think I'll figure it out
maybe I'm reading this wrong my main
issue with the new order was the lack of
adjectives the old blood fix this with
robot nazi zombie dogs oh I see what
he's saying do you think the new
Colossus would go further I certainly
hope so
no no ex ex what are you trying to do
there's a like I'm thing you can pull oh
there's a prompt [ __ ] you goofed
unless I'm mistaken sorely guess not
maybe a mistaken I would have our see
something do not have any ammo that more
companies
that's the way to go for this thing dual
wield shouldn't waste those grenades
thinking there was a buzz around I can
use that turret would be helpful be an
EMP me or Tesla me or ever was there we
go
Tesla grenade with Eze digit of t
starlight what do you think Jake and
Mike uh thought that suppose a sci-fi
like fallout of thing yeah I mean I
think that would've been really cool but
once again I don't know I think the test
is there they're gonna only start
showing up games a lot later this year
or later that year mm nope
John Luke was just telling me it's not
great ya heard it was a very sad
apparently gentle death Betty nice
cool I probably take more time gathering
stuff we're streaming but I'll check oh
yeah uh Mike and Jake which game devs
and distributors know best what gaming
is all about I really don't think EA has
a clue yet dice do as a negative example
what I mean alien so I guess trying know
which which publisher developer do you
think best understands gaming I have my
answer
I like Bethesda a lot if I think that
Bethesda does a great job of finding
like funding projects that you wouldn't
think like the first dishonored for them
to take that big of a risk undesired was
huge back in 2012 and now look at this
honored I mean Wolfenstein in general
reviving this reviving tomb seeing the
potential of those I like the Fez does
portfolio a lot what were you gonna say
I mean I was gonna say Rockstar which
someone already mentioned it and also in
terms of devs I think Steve Rogers ret
obviously I would say that me I mean but
in all honesty it seems like Nintendo is
really turned things around lately with
the upcoming projects it's good to see
they seem to be back on track with
people
sure
young player sure
probably be streaming for like another
ten to twenty minutes depending on where
we are the mission for those just
joining yeah this is PC version of
Wolfenstein the new order we figure we
play it because we've been a lot of
people the offices been replaying it
since new Colossus got announced at e3
hit potential fresh mountains it's so
we're going from this to doom
honestly I actually think this game is
harder than doom despite the fact that
doom is crazy but doom you're always
moving forward this you kind of want to
hang back but I'll shut up because this
is a good team finished early owl bubi
bubi Wolfenstein a movie in the same
game Frau angle and boobie I'm sure
things you might know it's pretty
terrifying under night lights this is my
sex toy boobie give revenge to the kiss
dizzy fish my lugar boobie
amazing as it is test midlife stitch
guide to stay there and then they
straight out of baby charity no I know
I'm do that special at me
I want to talk about okay so here's my
thing I don't know if this is a spoiler
because in new Colossus trailer they
show for out I know I could have sworn
you killed her in this game but I
misremembered apparently people said you
just print up your [ __ ] I'm destroy
but she doesn't die I thought she yes
she doesn't die she is the main
vulnerable main Voland vota finished e24
door apologies any German speakers each
eye socket chairman which excites you
the most the blue eyes I would say
I saw
I try to piss her off as an English good
food hours ghost butterfly I think will
piss her off
I think that's idle Feist my name's
Edith is a mononeuritis blue type palate
are you off in pure blood Bernard is mr.
BA on the pleasure in the face yeah see
this spider probably or no it's probably
this no I don't think skulls would
get the sounds own this is it Earl its
turbot can you [ __ ] this up I don't know
I don't think so I will kill booby in
Devon
and misses the damage on ensuring never
see such dark stuff disability from
Menon sushi
I never noticed that before she's
totally putting his hand okay
boobie my dramatic uzuki-chan yeah it
flows from Olga good she had a pretty
bad scar in the new trailer didn't she
yeah cuz you destroy but you kill him
while she's watching him and I was so
satisfied big tip she probably didn't
turn em upside I guess we didn't have a
feeling point
um I can't wait till I go to New Orleans
in the new game just like see
nazi-occupied America yeah I mean it's
not something I want to see in real life
but I'm sure I'll be fun like liberating
America kind of like you do Europe in
this dance bill the water that's really
cool that all the stuff you're doing in
this isn't isolated from the American
[ __ ] going on the rest of the world but
it's still like in the German war
machine is so vast that like there's
still so much left to do it with the one
presumably a third game or whatever they
do
serious though between last year and
hopefully the rest of this year it's
like a good time to be in two shooters
yes
last year multiplayer shooters were
between titanfall 2 and overwatch but
then of course single player in Doom yes
really good the genre seems to be making
a comeback
I'd like the pinnacle of shooters for a
while was like you know there's just one
event 2007 I think in like modern
warfare Halo 3 of it yeah oh that was a
crazy month November of 2007 was Mass
Effect halo 3 and The Orange Box came
out I'm pretty much like within two
weeks of each other I think this always
seemed abrupt to me oh there were they
already romantically entangled so maybe
when he was in a wheelchair she was
going at him 14 16 years cuz he had the
new game you're she's pregnant with your
twins which like the theme of twins
seems to be big like the new Colossus
the Statue of Liberty is a twin there's
a French one obviously the French made
both number there's one in France two
new cloths taken from the poem on the
Statue of Liberty that seems treated for
these waters give me your tired hungry
knows about it secret police
headquarters it's notorious here in
Berlin they bring prisoners inside for
questioning damn I didn't know that
portrayed him I knew they were censored
I content this game in Germany I didn't
know the swastikas we're all changed for
Wolfenstein logos something's happening
there's a prison transport arriving what
surprised me
I'm really looking forward to finally
killing Frau angle you know like in a
way that you know she's dead
like yeah why her head explodes into
Eisenbach prison head go down to destroy
the guard maybe he won't see you
what you think you're up late from our
10 and 15 minutes yeah you get to like a
checkpoint
[Music]
with advances
Chris say again my last question for now
do you think video games will ever exist
without polygons I think games will
truly advanced on no technology I have
no idea I don't know enough about
software to say that they always change
though so I'm sure we're nowhere near
the pinnacle of them you know what I'm
weirdly excited for and it's not that I
was not excited to see a press
conference so devoted to VR in terms of
Bethesda but I'm probably gonna
definitely try out fallout 4 in Skyrim
in VR oh yeah definitely and I'll
probably get Skyrim on my switch as much
as I'm so sick of Skyrim like it's a
great game but we're like we're really
we're all collectively as a culture
milking it um yeah for sure yeah but
like the thought of playing Skyrim on
mice which just sounds like yeah this
thing on the YouTube chat saying you
have to go to sleep but keep up the
great job over there I really apologize
I don't know how to pronounce your name
but thank you very much and thank you
for watching today as always um yeah I'm
I'm but also doom VR looks weird and so
counter to what I think of when I think
of the new doom from 2016 like forward
movement in this game you're like
teleporting and then shooting and then
teleporting then shooting yeah I don't
think all I'm not too interested in the
doom VR I'll try it out just to see the
doom weapons again and I always want to
replay to him from last year and this
honestly like shooters again the thing
might go to difference between this and
doom for me was that doom I like doom I
could only play like one mission at time
because it was so overwhelming like I
loved it but it was like alright I need
to like breathe yeah it's weird I feel
like what was the one to the first
titanfall release I think it's 2014
right if I'm not mistaken yeah early ish
or no it was a launch title for no it
was it was close to launch though I
think so people Jack
Craig knew very wrong so I think it was
early 2014 am I going that was also I
feel like that's when games first really
started to focus on movement as like a
big aspect like titanfall 2 well
titanfall titanfall 2 the new doom every
every Call of Duty with it starting with
advanced warfare then black ops 3
movement was always key Halo
I've they really started that stuff with
a Spartan pound or whatever you wanna
call it and the vaulting and it's weird
that this game seems to be coming out at
a time when you know like it seems like
this game is very different right you
kind of want to hang back and take your
time collecting ammo and stuff and total
you have to play a little more
conservatively I feel like despite that
it's really cool it's this weird
juxtaposition despite the fact that
you're doing an assault rifles and
shotguns you do have to kind of be
played a little safer in this game yeah
so she cuz you have health which is I
don't think there's recharging health in
Call of Duty World War two which is no
that why there might be a multiplayer
but there's not Mick that's so weird
call duty was the first one to spark
like that well I'd say halo 2 recharging
health yeah halo 2 had that you're
totally right was that that wasn't
before call duty did it though yeah cuz
Call of Duty it call duty 2 was the
first one that had recharging house I'm
pretty sure maybe you're right you could
be right
yeah cuz it's called 2d finest hour 1
before that damn but either way it's so
weird that a Call of Duty itself like I
think we look at Call of Duty is like
the the generic shooter despite the fact
that I actually liked infinite warfare
as if I don't play the multiplayer
anymore really but I'm looking forward
to seeing how World War 2 it makes sense
for a World War 2 game to have like
health but doom had it obviously
interesting how Call of Duty World War 2
also won't have the movement to I mean
it will ne won't have won't like if it
has Sprint's as much of an emphasis on
that I'm just knife and everything damn
make sure that dog was dead someone asks
you can get a kill with that a Tesla gun
you don't mind before we on the stream
absolutely assuming it just explodes
them I forget what happened but I love
how different doom is from this right
through ms so much about movement but
also like that loop between when you're
low on ammo you do the glory kills to
get ammo or is it health health right
yeah I think then chainsaw pills get
ammo but then also searching the
environment for the chainsaw fuel it's
just this cool loop between all the
different systems that honestly
it's okay you wanna be Tesla I like ya
but you stopped can you kill him no you
stop shooting after whoa uh yeah it's
weird um what is the Xbox one X is $500
right yeah it's weird I would love to
get that and play this on it I would
love to play like Far Cry 5 I would love
to play Metro Exodus and I'm sure we'll
have a few in the office which I'm
looking forward to trying out but right
now I can't see myself find that when
there's so many games coming out I know
I as soon as it the price drops or maybe
if I get like birthday money it's coming
out right around my birthday I'll just
I'll definitely pick up an Xbox one axe
and play every sugar possible on that I
think I'm gonna get it yeah because I
thought it would be a lot more I thought
it would be like honestly I thought I'm
gonna be like $6.99 I was thinking like
I was hoping it would be like 400 which
was unrealistic but 500 seems like what
we expected I get it yeah I mean closer
to when it finally like when they
finally announced I was like alright
it'll probably be like 500 but for a
while there I was like 4k gaming kind of
concepts can be like 800 bucks
Chris a saying one other short question
any fast action first person shooters
without unskilled teenagers playing fast
action first-person shooters it depends
on what you can put like fighting fall
to is one of my favorite shooters in a
long time favorite games last year one
of them
I would encourage playing that but also
rainbows succeed if you want tactical
there's more skilled people worse
Rainbow six siege is fantastic game this
oh yeah there we go someone else was
said by titanfall - it's on sale
apparently there's DLC out ok - I think
new Titan just came out titanfall seems
unreal um battlefield 1 has in the name
of this our DLC coming out soon this is
a good time to end it Jake you think
after that see ya watch the rest of this
comes down and shut up a little bit
friends if this is where they're keeping
you I will find you set you free cool uh
I'm gonna end it there I guess sure so I
could play this all day but we gotta
knees do other things huh
cool uh yeah for those that just watch
thank you so much for joining us as we
played Wolfenstein the new order yeah
Jake and I I think in the future this
stream will become if you watch our
reboot show you know it goes up on
Sundays and we usually talk about one
specific game with a few others to
support some sort argument but today we
just felt like playing a new order
Monday for a week from today we have off
in our us office for our weekend I feel
like sucks because we haven't done like
two weeks in a row this has always been
something like yeah and then if a Monday
off and then e3 and then yeah um but if
you do watch reboot we're actually I'm
talking a little bit about half-life 2
which is kind of intimidating but I'm
mainly talking about Metro last light I
we get put up an episode yesterday I've
reset our off week episode where we talk
about these games we're covering but I
don't want I don't want to tease them
too much because if we have to pivot
last minute but yeah we're doing a Metro
last light after the Metro Exodus
announcement at e3 I figured be a good
time to talk about last light which a
lot of people played about I don't think
enough so hopefully this encourages more
people play it and maybe we'll stream at
the following Monday if it makes sense
one of my favorite games of all time and
criminally underappreciated yeah this is
one sign new order on PC looking forward
to a new Colossus the second game on
October 27th Jake what else are you
playing this week besides this
uh man I need to play I want to play
more of Metro last light as well yeah I
got a ton of reductions on sale on uh I
mean I already have it on yeah well for
people watching you get Metro redux on
scanner yeah I bought a ton of games I
got holo night I want to play holo night
yeah but - I haven't played that yet
shadow of mordor on PC not a fan of it
but I thought I'd give another try
because it was like 275 or something
like that it's like alright well are you
fan of it now that you have you know
played it you haven't played yet I just
done I mean I played run name Xbox one
when it came out or ps4 whatever but
also yeah yeah for anybody joining
YouTube twitch games watch ass thanks so
much for joining will have streams
throughout the week Selda DLC Robin Pete
will be streaming that later Eric
tomorrow will be playing Diablo 3 the
necromancer comes out [ __ ] I forgot
about that I'm going to play that so
much this week as well necromancer care
comes out yeah anyway as always thanks
for stopping by I'm sure we will see
everybody later and uh thanks for
watching thank you